issue because if we don't essentially if
we don't say like trans women can't
compete we're
we're putting ourselves in
kind of in danger because
in sports especially in a contact sport
if you're going up against somebody and
say like say we're post and we're going
up against a trans woman we're we're
about to get bodied and it could
seriously injure us because
as a even as a guard say you're driving
you're driving uh down the lane and
someone just bumps you a little bit it
can send you flying
like
like a
career and an injury yeah and i've had
friends who've competed against trans
women i've competed against trans women
and they've told me that
yeah this person came down the lane and
they just bumped me just a little bit
and it sent them like a flying and it's
just
you're putting like essentially it's
just a dangerous situation yeah and so
but it's like
it's like you guys are both so logical
like you know this so i feel like we
should be like
like it shouldn't even when i ask you
like would you stand for that policy
like there should be no hesitation and i
and i but i understand because i think
as women we have this like empathy
yeah we want to include people we want
to
and it's like natural times yeah and i
have that too but
i just i i oh my god it just makes me
really mad
yeah
because i just think of myself like i've
worked so hard to get to this point
so hard like i i've put in god knows how
many hours to get as good as i am
exactly and i can maybe go to europe and
get free housing and a couple hundred
bucks a month yeah
and i want to share that with men yeah
or go to a [ __ ] country and make decent
money but i'll be on an island with more
goats than people like what do i have
money
it might even become harder like to get
like opportunities in the future if what
if in the future oh goodness like our
leagues are filled by trans and they
just take it
see that's that's that's where like we
like but that's what i feel like like
yeah because we yeah because we keep
letting it go and i think that's what
like that's what we did
eight years ago
instead of saying like why the hell is
caitlyn jenner getting a female award
remember she got the the courage award
like the female courage award
yeah i'm like why the hell is she taking
away like someone else's award
like you're telling me caitlyn jet like
come on like
let's just pull up a picture
wait kate when and so essentially
all the accolades that caitlyn jenner
had
before
when she was a man
do those go away now like there's no
more chris no no
she still has like the record books or
whatever but
that's not that's not
her anymore
i don't know
i think it's it's stealing bruce has
like bruce
yeah if like a man that's transitioned
was previously a gold medalist in the
men's like 100 meter yeah and they
transitioned to a woman is that still
his title or does that get passed down
like
oh i don't
i don't know but like
if me i would just live in reality and
say you can dress up as a girl but you
won't actually be a girl yeah you can be
a trans woman that's why if i say like i
say trans woman because you can't carry
children yeah you can't like you don't
have to go through pain
once a month
every month every month
you don't have to
that's that's like the one thing that
does upset me is it's so easy for
i'm not saying it's easy for them to
transition but it's easy for people to
say oh you're a woman
and
it's just like there's
there's so much that comes with being a
woman and it's not just to say that
women are just this just that but that
comes with being a woman and there's no
going around and there's no if ands or
buts about it and
people can come in and transition and
they can choose to be a woman i wish i
could choose not to have a period of
money i mean i could choose not to
have just the womanly things that happen
to us that are heart i wish i could
choose to not have to operate in pain a
lot throughout the day and
it's just
that's like the irritating thing about
it yes i want to be respectful of the
choice respectful of
how they see themselves and how they
live their lives but it's just like
it's hard it's like so there's this
this is not about um
uh trans people there's this person
who
and she's like
i'm black i identify as a black person
it's just like wait how how
you were
you are not born and she went to africa
and got blessed and
everything and
it's not it's not that
there's another lady she's um
she's from over on this side yeah world
but it's like
it's kind of
there's a lot of things that yeah like
yeah what if i woke up instead of
instead of the whitest girl on earth i'm
now the blackest girl like a purple i
would be like you know what girl
don't ask me to be on your podcast no
more that's what i'm saying like it'd be
disrespectful because there's struggles
like black people go through that i
don't yeah and me like claiming like
getting tanned one day like yeah
painting my skin like it's the same
thing that they're doing but why is like
i don't understand why is that
acceptable but like one is acceptable
and one is it that is true yeah i think
it's just the way that society is now
though
they're trying to normalize a lot of
things and they're trying to normalize
like
tran like trans women trans men like
yeah and where where like nowadays we
can't even
speak some and say like she or she's
like
yeah i mean
i mean i'm still cool
yeah like unless they get offended
whatever but it's like sometimes
nowadays you have to be wear full of
stuff like that yeah that's how society
is that site is starting to construct
this way for us to think yeah we have to
be whip like yeah wary of things like
that that's why
yeah that's why it's hard to just say
like no she can't compete you know i
mean yeah
it's like almost like we're pro like i
don't think it's natural because i like
i feel like a lot of people like
listening to me because i'm like no
that's not real
and it's kind of like like a lot of
times when i say something like like i
feel like people are like programmed to
be like politically correct you don't
want to offend anyone i will say that is
true yeah
you don't you're like this is it and
this is it i remember the first time
that i came on the podcast with you i
was like i was like oh you're pouring
forward i felt a little bit no no no but
it was good now like i i understand
where you come from and why it is that
you you think the way you do and that's
that's perfectly fine
um
it's just i feel like
there's certain things in society
that
we have made like
touchy subjects it's like
don't we cannot talk about this because
it's
you don't want to you don't want to say
the wrong thing and it's just like but
what if i'm just expressing my opinion
can is my opinion wrong if it's not
agreeable to yours and i think that's
when it comes to when it comes to that
side of the
lgbtq plus community
i think that that's one of the touchy
places and correct me if i'm wrong on
that